[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
micky serien guten abend an diesem
samstag wir bringt sie auf den neuesten
stand und katja es bleibt dabei es geht
einfach nicht ohne gold und silber und
bronze kam heute noch dazu schon genannt
also zum einen sportliche erfolge zum
anderen sorgen über eine vielleicht
erhöhte kriegs wahrscheinlichkeit hier
sind unsere themen
ukraine krise spitzt sich zu das
auswärtige amt befürchtet militärische
auseinandersetzungen und ruft deutsche
auf das land zu verlassen
aus für 2g und zweige plus bund und
länder wollen die beschränkungen
schrittweise zurücknehmen
kanada greift gegen korona proteste
durch polizisten versuchen die
lastwagenfahrer vom wichtigsten
grenzübergang zu den usa zu vertreiben
es sind alarmierende botschaften die aus
den usa kommen washington warnt vor
einer russischen invasion in die ukraine
noch vor ende nächster woche russland
weist das zurück spricht von propaganda
zu den wachsenden spannungen gab es vor
zirka zwei stunden auch ein telefonat
zwischen den präsidenten beiden und
putin und wie klaus brodbeck berichtet
fordert nach den usa und anderen
inzwischen auch die bundesregierung ihre
bürger zum verlassen der ukraine auf in
der sprache der diplomatie ist das ein
deutliches zeichen deutschland zieht
alles personal aus der botschaft in kiew
ab das vor ort nicht unbedingt benötigt
wird auch deutsche staatsbürger soll die
ukraine möglichst verlassen so die
außenministerin am nachmittag in ägypten
das auswärtige amt spricht außerdem eine
reisewarnung für die ukraine aus
deutsche die sich dort aufhalten werden
für ausreise aufgefordert
bereits zuvor hatten die usa und weitere
westliche länder aber auch russland ihr
personal in der ukraine drastisch
reduziert immer martialisch werden die
bilder russischer militärischer stärke
putins truppen starteten heute ein
großmanöver zusammen mit de la rosa an
dessen grenze zur ukraine
fieberhaft laufen derweil diplomatische
bemühungen am morgen telefonierten die
außenminister der usa und russlands am
späten nachmittag dann noch beide
präsidenten
unsere botschaft ist überall dieselbe
wir sind bereit zum dialog aber eine
erneute aggression gegen die ukraine
hätte einen drastischen preis
denn wir sehen auf militärischer ebene
keine zeichen für die eskalation im
gegenteil in kiew demonstrieren sie für
die freiheit der ukraine präsident
selensky demonstriert bei einem
truppenbesuch man sei vorbereitet worauf
auch immer
wir müssen jeden tag bereit sein nicht
erst seit gestern und schon 2014
deswegen sind wir hier
unterdessen setzen die usa ihre
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine ford
montag wenn olaf scholz nach kiew
dienstag dann nach moskau reisen was er
putin dann sagen wird vom kasseler heute
kein wort
sprechen wir jetzt mit unseren
korrespondentinnen in berlin und
washington claudia bertz und contra
banerjee zunächst zuschlag und alaa die
situation scheint sich weiter
zuzuspitzen auch deutschland schließt
sich der reisewarnung der usa an fordert
bundesbürger auf die ukraine zu
verlassen was bedeutet das das bedeutet
dass die bundesregierung auch nicht mehr
zu 100 prozent ausschließen möchte dass
russland nicht dass russland
einmarschieren könnte ihnen die ukraine
und wenn man zu diesem ergebnis kommt
dann muss man als bundesregierung
schauen dass man deutsche staatsbürger
in der ukraine keinem unnötigen risiko
aussetzt vor allem mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter zum beispiel des
diplomatischen dienstes aber auch
diejenigen die dort für den
wirtschaftlichen aufbau zum beispiel
unterwegs sind die können jetzt
ausreisen weil man eben die lage doch
für da ausreichend ernst hält das
deutschland allerdings gemeinsam mit den
verbündeten weiter auf eine friedliche
lösung setzt das sieht man an der hohen
taktzahlen der diplomatischen telefonate
frankreichs präsident marc reinhardt
heute nachmittag mit wladimir putin
telefoniert danach gab es auch einen
telefonischen austausch zwischen jacob
und olaf scholz also man sieht die
gespräche sind da sehr eng dem vernehmen
nach
hat putin im gespräch mit macken
beteuert dass kein einmal vorstände aber
wir sehen eben an den entscheidungen
auch des auswärtigen amtes dass die
sorge angesichts der russischen
militärischen bewegungen doch größer ist
als das vertrauen in dieses wort und
dass man deswegen heute reagiert hat
dann fragen wir claudia bates in
washington die töne aus den usa die
wurden zuletzt ja immer drängender heute
gespräche auf höchster ebene die beiden
präsidenten haben telefoniert also usa
und russland aber auch die außenminister
was ist dabei herausgekommen wonach
sieht es jetzt aus
ja das gespräch zwischen präsident biden
und präsident putin hat eine stunde
gedauert es wurden noch mal die
bekannten positionen im grunde
ausgetauscht präsident biden hat
präsident putin noch mal mitgeteilt
welche konsequenzen ein einmarsch in die
ukraine hätte er hat auch hingewiesen
auf menschliches leid auf großes
menschliches leid was ein einmarsch
verursachen würde und er hat putin
versucht deutlich zu machen dass auch
das ansehen russlands in der welt leiden
würde unter einem solchen angriff die
usa versuchen insgesamt
russland darauf zu drängen auf eine
deeskalation und sie sehen diese die
eskalation nicht auch in dem gespräch
zwischen den außenministern hat lauf
offenbar nicht zu erkennen gegeben dass
russland bereit ist zu deeskalieren und
die usa möchten da auch die diskrepanz
aufzeigen dass russland einerseits
leugnet einen angriff geplant zu haben
und gleichzeitig die den
truppenaufmarsch weiter fortsetzt die
usa setzen weiter auf diplomatie
versuchen alle beteiligten davon weiter
zu überzeugen dass das der richtige weg
ist und präsident biden möchte sich auch
im verlauf des tages noch mit
europäischen verbündeten darüber
austauschen dann vielen dank nach
washington claudia bertz und nach berlin
schack unterlag banerjee wir kommen
jetzt zur corona lage in deutschland und
der pandemie und den aktuellen zahlen da
meldet das robert-koch-institut
1789 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 8.000 26 weniger als vor einer
woche
198 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage inzidenz steigt nur leicht auf
1.474 3 also teils sinkenden zahlen und
steigende erwartungen dass bald
gelockert wird norwegen hat jetzt
ebenfalls so gut wie alle corona
beschränkungen aufgehoben öffnungen
brachte gestern ja auch der
bundeskanzler ins spiel insofern darf
man auf die nächste bund länder runde am
mittwoch gespannt sein der
wirtschaftsminister der hat schon mal
einen stufenplan formuliert über pläne
und hoffnungen christoph distel
raus aus der omicron tristesse und ihren
strengen regeln momentan geht es zum
beispiel so ab nach mallorca wo die
sonne scheint und schon kein zweig mehr
gilt man könnte für mehr freiheit aber
auch einfach abwarten da geht was glaubt
wirtschaftsminister habeck denn in der
kommenden woche soll die infektionswelle
auch bei uns brechen
daher ist die nächste
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am 16.2 der
richtige zeitpunkt um sich engel bei
erste öffnung schritte abzustimmen und
das ist sein plan
zuerst will er die maßnahmen lockern die
staat und wirtschaft besonders viel
kosten etwa wo derzeit zweig und 2g plus
gelten zb in kino- oder gastronomie dort
soll künftig das tragen von fft zwei
masken ausreichen und zur freiluft
veranstaltungen sollen wieder mehr
besucher kommen dürfen in einem zweiten
schritt könnten dann weitere regeln
fallen die home office pflicht etwa die
3g pflicht am arbeitsplatz und masken
müssten nur noch in büros getragen
werden wo es enger zugeht noch ist nicht
klar ob auch an schulen weniger tests
weniger massen geplant sind die
präsidentin der kultusministerkonferenz
wäre aber ausdrücklich dafür ziehen muss
doch sein für kinder und jugendliche
endlich wieder normalität zu erreichen
denn kinder und jugendliche leiden
massiv unter den rahmenbedingungen der
der pandemie auch intensivmediziner
befürworten lockerungen aber doch bitte
nicht zu früh
wir sollten dann erst auch wirklich die
maßnahmen durchsetzen wenn unsere
wesentlichen indikatoren und dazu gehört
die belegung in den krankenhäusern dazu
gehören die neue aufnahme auf die
intensivstation
auch wirklich runter gehen wie gesagt
man könnte der omicron tristesse reisend
entkommen oder noch ein bisschen geduld
haben die meisten maßnahmen entfallen
hier zu lande vielleicht bis mitte märz
morgen ist es wieder soweit ein neuer
bundespräsident wird gewählt oder eine
neue bundespräsidentin aber der neue
wird wohl auch der alte sein die
wiederwahl von frank walter steinmeier
gilt als sicher er hat die unterstützung
der ampel parteien und der union
mitbewerber sind der sozialmediziner
gerhard trabert für die linken der von
der afg aufgestellte ökonom max otte und
die astrophysikerin stefanie gebauer die
von den freien wählern nominiert wurde
patricia wiedemeier berichtet
das spannendste am morgigen tag dürfte
sein die unter corona bedingungen eine
bundesversammlung durchgeführt wird
nicht wie sonst im plenarsaal sondern im
paul-löbe-haus werden die wahlfrauen und
männer auf fünf etagen sitzen in den
sitzungssälen und den büros der
abgeordneten dass frank walter
steinmeier wieder gewählt wird gilt als
sicher er wurde von den ampel parteien
und der union nominiert für die spd ist
die wahl steinmeiers ein zeichen von
kontinuität in schwierigen zeiten und da
braucht es jemanden des
bundespräsidenten der in der lage ist
brücken zu bauen der in der lage ist
menschen zusammenzubringen der in der
lage ist auch eine sprache zu finden die
das land zusammenhält und vereint und
diese personen haben wir mit frank
walter steinmeier auch die fraktionen
von union und fdp tagen heute ohne
anschließende statements ebenso fdp und
linke die er beide mit eigenen
kandidaten morgen in die wahl gehen
insgesamt 1400 72 mitglieder hat die
bundesversammlung die eine hälfte
stellen die bundestagsabgeordneten die
andere hälfte entsenden die länder
darunter landtagsabgeordnete
kommunalpolitiker und personen des
öffentlichen lebens wie zum beispiel
musiker für einige von ihnen ist klar
dass sie für steinmeier stimmen werden
oder für mich eben gegen polarisierung
wirkt weiter verbinden drückt wolle
ausgleichend wirken ich finde das
wichtig für unser land er geht irgendwo
hin dann wird er gefilmt und man sieht
wie ihr läuten zuhört die eher selten
gehört wenn das eine sache die ich sehr
sympathisch findet morgen ab 12 uhr
beginnt die wahl ein ereignis das es so
in der regel nur alle fünf jahre gibt
sachsen wehrt sich gegen eine
weiterbeschäftigung des fdp politikers
jens maier als richter das
justizministerium stellte an den antrag
den vom verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextrem eingestuften 60-jährigen in
den ruhestand zu versetzen nach seinem
bundestags ausscheiden als ehf
delegierter plant meyer ab mitte märz
wieder als richter tätig zu sein
trucker proteste gegen eine krone
impfpflicht lehman seit zwei wochen
teile kanadas und jetzt greifen die
behörden durch die polizei hatte
angefangen erste blockaden zu räumen
nämlich die an der m bester bridge einer
wichtigen verbindung zu den usa auch in
der hauptstadt ottawa könnte es bald
soweit sein dort haben sich die trucker
rund um das parlament häuslich
eingerichtet und aus ottawa zeigt uns
dass jetzt johannes hano
sie hupen und sie feiern die ganze nacht
seit zwei wochen blockieren hunderte lkw
sowie hier vor dem parlament die
kanadische hauptstadt ottawa die die
gekommen sind wollen die regierung
loswerden wie in eine in pflicht
auferlegt hat hinter der viele eine
verschwörung vermuten
wir haben keine kontrolle über unsere
körper mehr alles wird von der regierung
bestimmt meine meinung nach tyrannisch
erinnern sie sich nicht mehr daran was
sie mit den juden gemacht haben bin ich
jetzt ein junger bin ich ein hund in die
wunde spritzen sie mikrochips und das
wollen sie jetzt allerdings machen
es ist nur eine vergleichsweise kleine
gruppe der mehr als 200.000 kanadischen
lkw fahrer direkt angeschlossen haben
aber die sind gut organisiert und
blockieren strategisch wichtige punkte
mit ihrem besser der brücke über die
täglich fracht im wert von etwa 300
millionen dollar zwischen den usa und
kanada transportiert wird die blockaden
werden zum wirtschaftlichen problem kann
er das premierminister jetzt
durchgreifen
alles ist jetzt auf dem tisch denn diese
gesetzlosen aktionen müssen enden und
sie werden endet
auf dem besser der brücke hat die
polizei jetzt damit begonnen lkw-fahrer
abzudrängen und einzukreisen in der
provinz ontario gilt seit heute nach der
notstand der der polizei weitreichende
vollmachten einräumt bis zu 70.000 euro
bußgeld und ein jahr gefängnis droht
jetzt all denen wie die strafen weiter
blockieren auf antrag der
provinzregierung wurden auch die
spendenkonten für die proteste
eingefroren ganz überwiegende teil der
spendengelder kommt aus dem ausland vor
allem aus den usa ein kleiner teil wohl
aber auch aus deutschland
heute ist der erste berlinale samstag
das hieß ja eigentlich große partys
empfänge schaulaufen in diesem jahr sind
aber alle froh dass die filmfestspiele
trotz bewohner überhaupt stattfinden
können mit im wettbewerb der neue film
des deutschen regisseurs andreas dresen
er erzählt die geschichte des in
deutschland geborenen guantanamo
häftlings murat kurnaz aus der
perspektive seiner mutter stephan
merseburger hat mehr
andreas triesen geht mit rabbi kurnaz
gegen george hw bush in den wettbewerb
der film erzählt eine wahre geschichte
von recht und willkür vom scheinbar
aussichtslosen kampf einer mutter um
ihren sohn in ihrer verzweiflung wendet
sich rabbi comas an einem
menschenrechtsanwalt
wo setzt er
ist in guantanamo wird gefoltert und
fünf jahre als angeblich
terrorverdächtige dort gefangen gehalten
grundlos erst 2006 kommt der bremer
türken murat kurnaz endlich frei obwohl
deutschland ihn schon 2002 hätte
rausholen können du meinst meine eigene
von mir gewählte rot grüne regierung
verhindert dass er wieder einheiten
absichtlich
scheiße
chef des kanzleramtes es war damals
frank walter steinmeier er trägt
verantwortung dafür dass kurnaz nicht
zurückgeholt wurde wenn man es dann
später besser weiß sollte man zu diesen
fehlern stehen und auch den mut haben
und die moralische größe zu sagen das
war falsch das tut mir leid und diese
geste vermisse ich auch von unserem
jetzigen bundespräsidenten und ich würde
mir wünschen dass er vielleicht noch mal
darüber nachdenkt
desto gegen den präsidenten der
vereinigten staaten klar ist wer
oder ende triumphiert sie und damit die
menschlichkeit
und wir sind jetzt beim sport und wieder
gute nachrichten katja giegold wie war
wahnsinn kann man sagen und es immer
wieder am eiskanal im weltcup hatte es
hannah heise bislang hatte bislang noch
nicht einmal aufs podium geschafft jetzt
ist sie tatsächlich olympiasiegerin im
skeleton fast hätte es sogar noch bronze
für deutschland gegeben aber tina
hermann verpasste platz drei um knapp
drei zehntel
nach zwei von vier läufen ist olympia
debütantin hannah neiße noch in
lauerstellung dann rast sie souverän dem
sieg entgegen
die 21 jährige aus winterberg lenkt
ihren schlitten ohne größere probleme
durch den anspruchsvollen eiskanal von
lenzing
triumph der früheren junioren
weltmeisterin sie ist jetzt erste
deutsche olympiasiegerin im skeleton
ich denke dass dort noch ein bisschen
bis ich das wirklich realisieren auf
jeden fall ist es gerade wirklich ein
unbeschreibliches gefühl
gold für hanna neiße vor der
australierin jacqueline rickert und
kimberly bus aus den niederlanden
und das war nicht die einzige medaille
für team deutschland heute geiger ließ
auf der großschanze die probleme der
letzten tage hinter sich und springt zu
bronze und sogar silber etwas
überraschend gab es im langlauf dank
einer hervorragenden mannschaftsleistung
nach ihrem zielspurt liegen sie sich in
den armen die frauen langlauf staffel
über 4 x 5 kilometer silber hat das
deutsche quartett geholt mit einem
klaren matchplan wir sind dran geblieben
und haben das was wir uns vorgenommen
haben gesetzt und das war eine defensive
herangehensweise an das rennen catherine
sauerbrei katharina hennig viktoria kahl
und sophie krauel nach langen tiefs bei
den langläuferinnen und langläufer nein
toller medaillen lichtblick gold gewinnt
das russische team bronze holt schweden
apropos bronze er schreit seinen dritten
platz förmlich raus karl geiger im
ersten durchgang auf einem
aussichtsreichen sechsten platz liegen
springt der im finaldurchgang erneut auf
138 meter gold holt der norweger marius
lind wick und silber er springt der
japaner ryo kobayashi
[Musik]
neben olympia gibt es tatsächlich auch
noch andere themen fußball bundesliga
zum beispiel wobei die bayern diesen 22
spieltag wahrscheinlich lieber vergessen
würden hier die ergebnisse die bayern
verlieren deutlich verlieren deutlich in
bochum 2 zu vier gladbach besiegt
augsburg 3 zu 2 wolfsburg gewinnt in
frankfurt zwei zu null freiburg mainz
spielen unentschieden eins zu eins
greuther fürth schlägt härter zwei zu
eins am abend die partie leverkusen
gegen stuttgart ausführlich und erstmals
im freetv im aktuellen sportstudio
bereits gestern leipzig köln drei zu
eins in der tabelle bleiben die bayern
trotz der niederlage deutlich vor
dortmund und leverkusen die aber noch
punkte gutmachen können dahinter die
leipziger die von sieben auf vier
klettern dann freiburg und union
frankfurt jetzt in der zweiten
tabellenhälfte ganz oben dahinter keine
veränderungen in der reihenfolge zur
vorwoche augsburg auf dem
relegationsplatz ganz unten stuttgart
und führt und um auf der heutige
sportstudio gast das max kruse
torschütze heute guter typ wird net
23.30 geht's los dann fielen dann katja
das noch von uns es gibt eine eisige
nacht aber danach viel sonne mehr gleich
von özden terli um 23.15 erwartet sie
christian sievers zum heute-journal wir
danken fürs zuschauen freuen uns wenn
sie morgen wieder dabei sind schön dank
und schönen abend dann mit barbara
[Musik]
ein schön beamte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter heute gab es sehr viel
sonnenschein und morgen wird das auch
noch so sein dass hoch schwindet
allerdings und verabschiedet sich
langsam nach osten dafür kommt relativ
milde luft an und ein neues tief
erreicht uns dann am montag in der
kommenden nacht viele wort nach norden
sonst lockert es häufig auf die sterne
zeigen sich es wird kalt temperaturen
sinken auf minus ein bis minus zwölf
grad null grad gibt es an der ostsee
eigentlich frostfrei richtung nordsee
bei 1 bis 2 grad morgen dann viel
sonnenschein im süden und auch nach
osten hin im tagesverlauf werden die
wolken von westen und südwesten her
etwas dichter es bleibt aber noch
trocken und das bei höchsten
temperaturen von fünf grad an der ostsee
und bis 14 grad im südwesten
deutschlands ziemlich mit wir schauen
auf die nächsten tage und am montag
kommen die schauer von westen her und
beschränkten sich hauptsächlich auf den
westen nach südosten hin viel
sonnenschein bei 7 bis 14 grad ja und am
dienstag weitere schauer mittwoch dann
kräftige regen und es kann wieder
stürmisch werden damit ein schöner amt